welcome to another episode of programmer
who Murr
I'm your host Matt you can call me like
I have any control over what you guys
call me you think I have any control
sitting behind this camera and screen
and mic and stuff I don't I'm just I
just get to stand here and everybody
gets to judge me all right let's get
into it the serve there was the top geez
talk about butchered opening survey for
upcoming hackathon
this isn't humor this is actual survey
for upcoming hackathon that's not what I
came here for but okay that sounds cool
hackathon is an event typically lasting
several days and which large number
people meet engage in collaborative
computer programming discourse so maybe
that's worth checking out what do you
guys think should it should I get
involved in the hackathon reminder this
is not a general tech humor subreddit
it's in the name if your post isn't
directly related to programming it will
be removed someone seems a little bitter
related to programming yeah so they're
very very specific about this
programming humor cool hot linking not
allowed without permission no lobbyists
reposts okay common posts will be
removed titles must be creative high
effort are and related to the content
okay let's get into it accurate I am
developer oh they can Twitter recruiter
hey I came across your github profile
and seen as it didn't 404 I think you'd
be perfect for this role okay not not
funny
I get it fine it's like that it's just
not a good joke why what do you want
it's not funny why is this the top one
huh
okay let's let's just dig into this why
would this be funny so how does your
github ever 404 you can change your name
and you didn't update your link you made
the link wrong which means you're
someone that's not fit for any role ever
and develop a role and that's my opinion
I mean don't push stuff to anything that
doesn't work obviously easier said than
done right three let's see what's three
you deleted your github account so like
those those are only three cases in
which that it wouldn't that it would 404
and not work you know so there's nothing
all that funny about any of those things
I get it that recruiters kind of say
this to you but they're just trying to
help you find a job and boost your
confidence a little bit that's not funny
that's nice of them you know it's people
to do that cheese is gonna be a rough
one I can tell by the top post being so
like not funny react that's right I use
react react I can't sit up node
environment don't you use no to setup
react I don't use them that often so
maybe someone will have to enlighten me
but yeah I think well I think you do you
like I don't know I don't know I really
don't
someone type it in the comments how you
said of react with node because that's
what you do right note is like a thing
you can do all sorts of j/s environment
stuff with I don't use it I should not
talk about it like I know about it
because I don't have used it like three
times and not enough to do anything okay
now what do we say about the titles the
titles have to be and are okay this is
the exact same thing that's not an
interesting title but the recursive sent
are half horse half recursive centaur
that's great I love the spiral it's just
it's satisfying too bad it's not a
slightly higher resolution render but
it's matter that much new Python
projects pip install package requirement
already satisfied pip show package name
package version okay I can use this
package make sense to me import package
module not found error no module named
package alright yeah that happens I
guess I'm gonna use Python that much who
uses Python people who don't want
efficient code that's who no I shouldn't
rag on Python I just don't use it that
much because I don't feel the need to
recursive Nichols I had a nickel for
every time I didn't know what was going
on and be like why do I keep getting all
these nickels Nicola peers where'd I get
this new where'd this nickel come from
another peers where'd this nickel come
from third nickel appears cycle repeats
indefinitely eventually realizes realize
there's a hole in my pocket
is this directly related to programming
I mean I can see that okay so when
you're programming there's so much to it
it's such a big world you're in scope in
general there's always stuff you're not
gonna know about popping up yeah maybe
I'm not in the mood to hear such jokes
but this doesn't seem very funny it's
just like okay that's like a it's like a
slapstick humor it's like it's like I I
tripped on a thing humor that's I
thought programmers were like
intellectuals who cares about
hypothetical appearing nickels you know
I don't it's not it's not a funny thing
to me it's just like alright whatever
okay C++ shorthand guide is your child
texting about programming languages what
your C++ obsessed teens texts actually
mean
oMG one more generic WTF where's the
function
FML for my loop i DFC indentation
doesn't feel
rekt lol logic on loop Friday vibes
productionserver my spaghetti code why
do people always make this joke about
messing up the production server why is
it funny what I don't I don't get it
that's not even a thing like at all you
don't put your code on the production
server you don't know so how does it get
updated it gets updated once in a rare
event when like you know everybody has
carefully tested everything if you're
pushing any kind of code the production
server you're doing it wrong
so what do you do instead why don't why
don't you do this how do you test your
code do you know the answer to this if
you don't if you have no idea might be
time for a career change programming
might not be for you
well hardware in general might not be
for you running environments that people
rely on and servers that people rely on
might not be for you probably isn't if
you haven't figured it out if you have
figured out okay you're good you're good
you can be here so what's the answer it
is you make a copy of the production
server and you test everything there
don't worry your company already has a
copy of the production server guarantee
you they probably have multiple if they
don't you should like help them get one
immediately and if they're not ok with
that idea you just turn in your
resignation letter and go somewhere
better cuz you you can't like operate a
company that relies on servers by
breaking the servers or risk breaking
the server's just do it in the duplicate
environments not that big of a deal
really use Clonezilla copy the hard
drive install it on the same system
however you want to do it there's better
ways than that but that's a free way you
could do it alright let's see next one
life sucks because of this
are you the IET support person for your
family sigh I love that they actually
put that as an answer have you tried
turning it off and on again I get it
yeah I uh most tech people end up being
the IT support person for their family
unless they're a whole family of techies
but why are you worried about it like if
you're a good enough tech to support to
be chosen as a person for family your
hopefully pretty good and if you're
pretty good you don't really have to
spend time on issues that's that's the
thing about IT that people don't realize
when they're new IT people and I didn't
realize it when I was a new IT people
you don't really have to spend time on
any of these issues that people talk to
you about you can just you can just know
the answer and be like stop talking
except you don't say it like that you
say like okay we can move on now I get
it
I'm not interested in here and all the
details we'll just fix it and move on
with our lives
so that way you can talk about whatever
you really want to talk about with your
family which you know might be nothing I
don't know who knows everybody has
different relationships with their
family hopefully you have one where you
can be honest with him because it's you
know like I have a I have one family
member that goes on and on and another
one that sometimes going on and on but
generally they learn pretty quick if you
explain it to them carefully like a
caring like a caring family member would
but if they don't need that if they just
want it fixed you can just fix it for
them but what's the problem I can't
figure out what the problem is then
you're not a very good idea support
person look it's the hard drive
it's the OS they have viruses again is
it something different than those three
things cause if it is it's probably real
obvious like you broke your screen you
smashed your laptop yes spilled coffee
on your motherboard you know there's
there's not like a big variety of things
it's like pretty much always hard driver
OS reinstall the OS who cares stop
listening to him to say we're gonna
reinstall your OS get out of the way of
course
you backup their data and do all that
stuff first but it's that takes like a
couple clicks it's like five minutes of
time the set-up time to get everything
ready takes longer than the actual work
it's mostly just walking away and
waiting and then if they give you a tip
they you can overcharge don't ever
charge your family
I personally don't charge my family but
sometimes they're like buy your lunch
you know all right
takes a long time takes a long time to
say something in Java okay so what not
sure why that would be funny HelloWorld
me I am good in C language interviewer
then write hello world using C me good
indeed that's one sexy potato okay
Facebook's facial recognition wasn't
found just striking resemblance between
me and a potato and a good-looking
potato it is I may have to use this pic
when people talk about how AI will be
able to filter out disinformation at
scale did it really trying to look at
his face and see the resemblance but see
okay
yes dark hair there's a dark spot and
it's a little lighter over here
I guess what the color tones are sort of
matching his face he's got the same this
line here is that like his mouth
hilarious
I'm gonna be recognized as a potato all
right next one I love programming
okay what about title what did we say
about titles up here must be creative
high effort and relevant to the content
all right see this these are like
generic or just need a title I don't
know if programming sorry jorian 72 not
meaning the rail your title but you know
it's their rules
all right developer makes a simply
intuitive UI nice users
can anyone explain why cats do this why
do cats do this they probably like it
you know though they like being like
tested being weird cats are weird nobody
can explain cats why would I ask all
right well the thing about users and
them really using your UI like you
didn't intend is well here's what it is
for me here's why I click everything and
try weird stuff on your UI I want to see
how your program performs because if I'm
gonna use it at scale of any sort then I
need to know it's not gonna crash in the
middle of my work cuz if a crash in the
middle of my work and I lose everything
we're all mad and waste a bunch of time
in like after we do everything and it's
really not cool probably not gonna use
your program anymore so if I kind of
plan on using it or really want to test
it for use I'm gonna try a lot of weird
stuff click a lot of weird things just
to make sure it holds up because if it
doesn't hold up you're wasting my time
I don't want it to crash in the middle
of my project that would be really bad I
need to confirm that it doesn't so
that's why users kind of go crazy and
use those unintended then in my opinion
because yeah you can just follow
directions and and it'll work sure but
you just want to stress test it make
sure it's suitable for your environment
all right next one point me towards the
exit please what they're afraid of
vampire sunlight Superman kryptonite C++
beginners pointers oh hey look we're
getting a call let's let's check out
this Kohl guys it could be good hello
hello hello
you rang what is that what why would you
even call they just hung up after 10
seconds I actually get those calls all
the time
why does it happen does anyone know why
that happens it's very annoying makes me
kind of not want to have a phone all
right couple more and when we're done I
get some coffee check this out oh it's
gonna be green screened it's the Grinch
I'm looking down here cuz mice monitor
screens down there alright when they ask
you why you've added a module you aren't
using an actual code it's a surprise
tool that will help us later I guess I
kind of do that
alright so normally I say something like
did you relate to any of these cuz if so
you one did I relate to any of these I
think I kind of related to this one so I
guess I want to point me towards the
exit please well suppose Peters pointers
pointers aren't that you know they're a
little weird I'll give it that but
ultimately it doesn't really matter if
you use them or not it just depends how
you're doing functions and stuff I don't
really know what to say about this I
don't think beginners are afraid of
pointers I hope you can go look up
pointer basics there's not much to them
really there's like two things there's
like two symbols and they do two really
obvious things what's so hard about that
okay well we're out that'll do it for
this episode of programming Hueber hope
you enjoyed hope you keep it up keep
doing your thing you guys watching this
I really appreciate you and you got this
far that's super cool
you know I care about every one of my
viewers I hope you guys do well that you
you kill it out there in the business
world and this is turning out to be real
bad I was gonna quit here and I'm
walking away